the protesters are down the corner as we
[ __ ] speak
it's Wednesday the 3rd of June get your
[ __ ] together the church what's
happening now is brought to you by blue
chew listen guys lemon when you [ __ ]
woke up with a dick that could [ __ ]
you could hit somebody in the head with
these [ __ ] cops you you see these
cops do batons remember when you dick
was a [ __ ] baton but good old days
when you can [ __ ] wake up with
[ __ ] you know like ten too [ __ ]
hard on the day but as you get older
your wood starts to get a little weak
okay uncle Joey's got the fix you ready
for this one blue chew it's the first
chewable dick pill which means it works
fast blue Chu has the same fda-approved
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
this isn't horny goat weed you get from
[ __ ] some do with a ACDC shirt on and
some [ __ ] liquor store
this is science [ __ ] do me a
favor blue - blue - calm is running a
special offer for the family all right
what we're gonna do is blue chill down
get your first shipment free again
that's blue chew like get your first
shipment free when you press in code
Church and you only cost $5 shipping
okay get your first shipment free when
you press in code Church CH you are CH
and you just pay file alphabet for
shipping again that's blue like the
color your [ __ ] dick when you don't
have no [ __ ] for a month and blue and
chew like chew and [ __ ] bubble gum
and slinging dick all right so I thank
them for sponsoring the church and I
thank you guys I have listen even if you
don't have suffer from that dick let's
say he's gonna give a get the girl was
stabbed you don't want to show up you
want to show up with the best Dicky the
show boy right or wrong am i lying to
you what the [ __ ] are we talking about
do me a favor go to blue calm right now
and get your first shipment free when
you're pressing code Church just paint a
$5 shipping who's better than you the
sling dick I'm doing you a [ __ ] favor
[ __ ] kick this [ __ ] melee
the second changes we're gonna like of
the legends the church
Oh
loulou's edition what's going on you fat
[ __ ] a lot is going on in the
country but this is a now for you to
relax sit back scratch your nuts smoke a
joint with uncle Joey and that's it and
that's that why do young saya tea why
don't [ __ ] it you know turn that [ __ ]
TV off there's nothing but [ __ ]
[ __ ] on that [ __ ] TV number one I
want to thank somebody that hooked us up
last week [ __ ] big-time and I keep
forgetting because I'm a [ __ ] sack of
[ __ ] my main man over there [ __ ] the
sandwiches yeah uncle Paulie
uncle [ __ ] paulie's in Beverly Hills
and downtown I checked in him with him
yesterday to see if anything had
happened to his store in Beverly Hills
he said he would get back to me he
[ __ ] hooked this up that's my
favorite [ __ ] deli in this area the
spicy Italian is tremendous he brought
Steve Simone's
broccolini with [ __ ] eggplant I mean
I don't like eggplant but it looks
[ __ ] tremendously hydrogen Paul
listen guys if you're looking for a deli
in Beverly Hills go see my man out of
respect he's been feeding people
throughout this whole [ __ ] calamity
feeding people make him [ __ ]
sandwiches all right so listen I give
respect to who [ __ ] deserves respect
what's the name of the deli give hit it
again
uncle Polly's uncle [ __ ] them Pauly's
that's it and that's that so anyway let
me let me talk to you a lot going on and
everybody's got that tape on what the
[ __ ] they got to say and I got one thing
to tell you okay there's people who are
doing safe protesting I'm not against
protesting it's your First Amendment go
with it if you're happy but then there's
people out there just doing plain crime
those people are doing playing crime if
you're looking walk than what they're
doing is they have fucked-up hearts you
know I know because I was there that
confused a young you know I submitted an
audio story last week the audio boom the
day the night my heart went sour it was
like December 29th of 1979
like a month and a half after my mom
died it hit me and I went up against the
world what does that mean that I stepped
on a
be i steped if i saw a car cat on the
street i would run it over when i ran
over a cat but I had that anger inside
my soul and that anger is the same anger
those protestors have the breaking [ __ ]
and pee free [ __ ] that's not making a
difference but that's not what we're
here to talk about today I just want you
to understand that you know listen
there's good and bad and this was
happening as a bad situation the only
people who could bring good to us is us
you know by doing the right thing by
being courteous by being nice to other
people [ __ ] like that this is Scott and
you know you can't write this [ __ ]
script it's very scary but you can't
write this [ __ ] script oh you white
people one of the apocalypse all you
white people want to be zombies get
ready
it looks like [ __ ] zombie fell at
night I mean the destroyer mm oh they
destroyed all this drug Beverly Hills
but listen this gives everybody a chance
to rebuild I told you this was gonna be
a weird time in our lives because it's
gonna make us realize what's important
and what's not important this is we've
been this is a catastrophe but at the
same time it's a blessing it shows you
what you got to deal with what the [ __ ]
T are you really made of this is what
this shows you and listen you're talking
to a guy who for the first three weeks
of this thing was crushed I was falling
apart at the seams I would just hole
myself up together I made a decision
that has the man of the house I had to
keep like a [ __ ] nice face on to not
worry everybody because that's what the
man in the house does it that's a that's
what a man does you know those
protesters you see the ones that are
going down and and being whatever
they're men they're men some you know
the Coptic on his knee they're all men
that's what men [ __ ] do the other
thing that just children when I was
being a thief and Luton I never looted
it right let's get something clear but I
diluted in life it's the same [ __ ]
difference and it I I was lashing out
because somebody had wronged me somebody
had wronged me life had wronged me so
now I had a wrong everybody else that's
the game plan
you know man it lasted in my heart from
1980 to 1991 when I got into town in 92
because to has to spread calmly and
laughter you can't have that anger in
your [ __ ] heart so and I can sit here
and tell you that I went to a
psychiatrist and tell you that they put
me on Zoloft and pay that man like we
all know what the answer is okay I'm a
Catholic I'm a Santeria guy and I
respect Buddhism and karma and I believe
in all those things and I tell you you
know I meditate you guys look at me with
my little red helmet on my flag helmet
well at the end all my little workouts
when I'm stretching out the last thing I
do is I do the whole thing I take my
shoes off you know my posture I breathe
through my nose and I focus on my third
eye and I listen for birds chirping I
listens for the birds that's what I
focus on my breathing and the birds
chirping and that's what's kept me
together about this whole [ __ ] thing
we having contact with steve simone and
dean bell rang and a red band you know
it's kept me together but angering your
heart is just something that you have to
figure out and that's what these
protesters have to figure out and and
listen I'm angry too about what happened
I don't know what they're waiting on
their arrest of three [ __ ] guys but
you know you they're accessory to
felonies let's arrest these three guys
let's show them all with our in suits on
and let's all [ __ ] calm the [ __ ] down
and that's all we could do let's have a
good [ __ ] time I'm saying take that
[ __ ] number out it's Wednesday
morning it's a third you don't have the
rent big deal there's anybody I'm saying
there's no debtors prison I dared him to
come try to throw you out
especially now that ain't got time to
evict you so tell your landlord to suck
your dick you'll be out next money I
mean how took time and all that but my
what I was writing I was writing when
you hear these [ __ ] stories of me
saying these stories we laugh at it now
but I was a rotten [ __ ] person for a
while
it wasn't me it wasn't why really was
guys it really wasn't all those stories
I tell you I did him like I copped him
but looking back now 57 year old man who
wasn't me it was a state of my heart I
had anger I had anguish you know society
took my mother she didn't leave a will
nor Social Security so I wanted a look
I wanted a lash back at society with
everything I had and you know what
looking at it now wasn't the answer
ruined my life for years
the addiction [ __ ] me up for 27 years
and for 10 years I walked around with an
anger and my [ __ ] heart that you know
if I could kick a dog [ __ ] like that
like I was just an angry [ __ ] person
and once that left my heart you know
yesterday was June Monday was June 1st
I'm a month away from my 20 year
anniversary of my wife I met her July
1st of 90 at 2 tower the year 2000 and
when that came to my mind yesterday I
went somewhere else for like 20 minutes
because I was like what the [ __ ] is
going on that the last one he is and she
was one of the people who helped get the
anger out of my heart by just being her
you know by just being her so when you
watch those images just think about it
that way you know pray for them pray
that their hearts turn like mine did you
know and if if my heart could turn with
the anger I had their hearts could turn
alright so give everybody a break
we'll go on through tough times like I
said you don't have to read does anybody
else don't worry about it [ __ ] it
that doesn't make you any less of
anything of anything we're all in bad
positions here and we all have to adjust
it speaking of which you know what
that's why the best time to have friends
is now limit your circle a friend you
you find out it was your friend the last
[ __ ] two months you found out go to
them they need new therapist that's what
I use my friends for today on the
podcast I interviewed Ari Shaffir let me
tell him how much I thank the
man every day when I mentioned him you
guys will think he did this he said
visitor bro his actions have always
spoken louder than words were family
I could look at Ari Shaffir and tell you
he is my brother and if something
happened to Ari I got a stand next to
him protect them you know when are we
had that listened to all those specials
I did and whatever they sucked ass but
I'll tell you what you guys know I tell
you the truth I borrow my suck dick when
I watch myself on those Ari storytellers
that's who made me who I am today
that's what I am when I go back to
comedy I'm going back to that style of
comedy finished my career because that's
who I really am those stories were all
great they were all great I watched one
that two black dudes watched one I told
my mother I was [ __ ] like it showed
me that somebody else understood that is
his darkest Lee told me that for a
couple weeks I had dark humor I got
because of where I was 20 years ago
couple weeks ago I posted a video of a
black dude put a firecracker in his eye
listen to me
thirty years ago I would have tortured
that guy for a month to put that
firecracker on his side I would have
talked I would have talked him into it
for the small 20 to put the Firecracker
in his eye not because he was black oh
yeah oh well I'm not just because that's
the evil I had in my heart
some people saw the good side some
people felt the evil and they avoided me
but anyway with all that [ __ ] you got
your friends and I listen there's 20,000
comics funnier than me they're
structured with uh but the good thing
about comedy and this is what I totally
is the friendships you making comedy
I've made some tremendous friendships
and my friends have helped make my
career so for you [ __ ] to think
that Rogen was the one that put us on
the map Brogan opened the window
we all climbed in like ludus and are we
starting a project it was called
whatever this is
not happening and you know he fought
Comedy Central to get me on there so in
my heart I felt I had to do everything I
could for my friend not to embarrass him
when somebody opens up the door for you
you [ __ ] do the work double because
you don't want to embarrass him you're
gonna be the best you can even if you
don't want to because somebody [ __ ]
[ __ ] spoke up to you so you got a
double e do the [ __ ] work I don't
give a [ __ ] what you feel
this guy fourth to me so I had to go up
them [ __ ] level and if you watch each
of those things and you guys know I hate
watching myself I [ __ ] went off on
those things I didn't give a [ __ ]
because it was my brother Ari so he's on
the podcast today I hope you enjoy the
[ __ ] interview and that's it I'll be
a smoking reefer I'll talk to you in a
couple minutes
[Music]
how you doing buddy how are you my
friend who's that behind you so no you
know it's definitely going on wherever
you're at but there hasn't been a barber
open or anything
yeah there's no bar biz there's no
nothing so I finally had it I had it
like two weeks ago I had it I tried it
Porto Rican style I got out of the
shower and I got my hair wet and I got a
call but I would just cut little little
inches for me you know whatever and it
looked okay it looked a little dwarf I
noticed how much air I had lost in the
top already from this [ __ ] pandemic I
must be losing air from just with the
stress or whatever so yeah go man I
gotta shoot these videos for these guys
and they always tell me the Joey can you
darken your hair a little bit you're
supposed to be uncle Joey not grandpa
Joey so it's like a class that these
guys got then they send it out that's
fun so I went to Walgreens to buy some
nicotine gum
I didn't have my glasses
all right so you know me dog listen what
people don't understand about me is I'm
I'm an idiot savant like I'm good at
some things but some things I just [ __ ]
up and I just laugh at most people can
have life at their own mistakes so I
walked into [ __ ] whatever Walgreens I
get the nicotine thing and I go let me
get them I'm gonna cut my hand I'm gonna
get some hair dye so I can't see so I
just buy like whatever head dye I forget
to bring my glasses I come home I set
the hold their head right thing up it's
a piece of cake you put gloves on you
come on you put on your hair and you
calm your [ __ ] hair in the shower
when you stand there for 20 minutes what
I do is I usually shave
I killed time you know I get the loofah
I [ __ ] scrub my ass washer Anki yeah
you know I just take my time I have a
little chair in the shower if that's the
way it came it's a small shower but it
has a little corner you can just sit
there this time in the water in the back
of the hotel not much a space someday
I'm gonna take the whole wall down but
anyway don't make a difference I put the
[ __ ] thing in I come out of the
shower and I come out I go to dinner and
nobody says nothing to be about my new
hairdo yeah in fact my wife says to me
Jesus Christ you you can't wait to go to
a doctor a barber you're alright yes
[ __ ] up
it's so [ __ ] white like I don't give
a [ __ ] about the color of my hair you
know I just dyed it I can't believe it's
white I don't know what happened so I
had to shoot the video so I go what the
[ __ ] am I gonna do well back to
Walgreens but listen let me tell you
what happened when I got a shower that
day and I dried my hair and I'm dressing
also I want to throw the Box away and
there's a little black bottle in there
like I wonder what this black bottles
for I go maybe it's to touch up like
your mustache your eyebrows I know
ain't got time for this [ __ ] so I put
the thing away so then I realize like
wait a second am i this [ __ ] stupid
is that it - getting this [ __ ] stupid
so I go back to Walgreens two to three
days ago I get the same box of [ __ ] and
I figured out that that's the ink you
gotta put it in there you dumb [ __ ] and
shake what I do I just love the shampoo
on my hair like nothing I was like what
the [ __ ] is going on my hair's been
[ __ ] wider so I finally put the
[ __ ] thing in I mixed it up I took
the city you know old school cuz I used
to have my own there the first three or
four weeks of prison you gotta cut your
own hair you think anybody barber Gino's
hairstylist and so three now there's a
guy that cuts tons of black people in
and diagnostic there's no barber you ask
him for a bob and they'll probably smack
in the vase it's when you get to your
destination so you ready for this the
barber at my prison was a guy an
old-school cheek I know man he was in
there for cutting somebody like killing
somebody bleeds also barber but he would
only cut hair with a straight razor
that's a weird style of people don't do
that anymore especially in prison that's
the best yeah that's the best haircut
you could get is when somebody says
they're gonna cut your hair with a razor
you gonna look like [ __ ] Elvis I love
it - I love it
barber shops in New York where they go
like that BH I got a razor yeah great
and it's like it's so smooth after that
it's frightening though you've seen so
many mob movies that's how they take
people out yeah but not this guy would
cut your hair with a razor eight minutes
eight minute heck pop pop pop he'd use
his trimmers for two or three things and
after that he will [ __ ] out of that
huh
but I just figured out how to cut my own
I just do a little Puerto Rican trim a
little hoop do Peru
a little head dies so you look a little
[ __ ] natural you know hoopty-do this
[ __ ] it's opening Ari its opening or
opening here that's it retail up and
today I agree well does I go get a new
flow is everybody worried about Kong
Kevin is my [ __ ] tyrant it's opening
LA County is not uh and people that's
not gavin newsom and for maybe to get
about West Hollywood
Rizzo there's still batting that one
virus they're battling they ever cured
that yeah please let's get AIDS under
control for a second and then just over
West Hollywood add Ovid she had Kovac
somebody had Kovac done that but I'm
hearing that all those rock clubs
they're trying to figure out what to do
with all those places that includes the
Comedy Store they're gonna have a hard
time opening up a West Hollywood you
know rock n roll rouse now 24 confirmed
cases of employees there and I know and
I know a girl who got it from rock and
roll rouse really yep what the [ __ ] they
do is just like this was the filthiest
of all the [ __ ] rouse yeah I mean
that's how it is people try to get laid
there in the [ __ ] frozen fish oil
I'll join you I guess rock and roll
Ralph's has always been one of the best
of markets in the country of people
don't know rock and roll Ralph it is
like what is this place danceOn in the
daytime it's the Miller Hollywood it's
across the street from the sunset hotel
just in case you pick up a chick right
there no and it's been done let me tell
you something I used to go to the
[ __ ] I used to get liquor from raus
add a quarter to in the old days because
I lived people down the corner from
rouse ants down the old place tons of
women I used to pick up a rouse or meet
women
to get that place you want to come over
oh my god we just saw you at the calm I
knew I'd be like having like that you
don't even need that or else not a rock
and roll's didn't even need that you're
1:00 a.m. spot and they would go to they
get beers because they were staying at
that shitty hotel across the street the
dryden one yes but I used to go to that
hotel years ago I ended up in that hotel
many a [ __ ] night [ __ ] up with Bob
Bailey went in there that the hotel used
to be where you went home from the
comedy store me Bob Baker Jimmy Schubert
Marin that's just drugs and hookers that
was a long time ago we're still doing
coke 98 97 98 99 that Hotel on Sunset
was way you wind it out three nights a
week or in your building because Cory
Cuomo and and and the girl lived in your
Julia
Genesee huh did you see see what I I
gotta show you this
what you building looks like yeah I
thought I did you it yeah I drove by it
but do you remember the black girl with
the freckles they had AIDS and your
building and we used to always go to her
house Atlanta girl yeah cuz there was
old man that lived in that building you
Corey Cuomo gentry a bull and a polyp al
Holtzman Paula Bell Holtzman that's what
your building looks like now yeah gone
they finally did it yeah
they finally tore it down it's gone you
see pink tout right there and nothing in
between and when did they throw you out
seven years ago seven yeah seven years
ago and you used to [ __ ] knock it
down they kicked it in sued by the city
though you're gonna make it an eyesore
by the rich people at the top though
you're gonna make it a nice we're like
five will plant a garden on top so
you're just looking at greenery and like
now traffic it'll be bad like what why
would try to be bad yeah well hey
blossom every nice I could
ninety-seven you left to calm this store
and you either went to your building
when Holtzman lived in that building
there was Altman but there was also a
black girl light-skinned black girl that
had freckles and she was she was a
hooker
not a good-looking thing she had
diseases she had like sores on her body
I'm not [ __ ] kidding you you could
tell she had been involved in some nasty
[ __ ] or you and the guy didn't run
without the car
what's that [ __ ] Florida what's that
comedy club in Florida not Kate can I
can island that if people go down there
off the ball off the hog County Club
yeah off the hook comedy club was owned
by a different guy okay
the closing and it was off the hook
closed I think so I think it could cats
captain Brian's maybe captain Brian's
closed before whatever whatever was
before Captain Hook's there in 1998
closed he sold it for a big amount of
money this guy went in there in the
early mid eighties opened up a comedy
club became friends with [ __ ]
everybody and one day somebody came in
and built a development and gave this
guy a check this guy took that check
went to his Bank of Florida got it
cashed - all twenties put it in two
suitcases and flew out to LA and check
them to that hotel now he was like a
well-renowned comedy club guy at that
time that noun you went to his club from
Tuesday the Sunday it was well known you
weren't sleeping I had never worked for
his club I had never met the guy so he
had moved out here and once he moved out
here I have to ask you Bert what the
guy's name was it was he bought an ounce
of coke a night for a month
really
and he just was wet for it the party
started at the Comedy Store and from
there it just ended somewhere till 6:00
in the morning when did coke die at the
Comedy Store
whenever Joey Diaz left not really no
not really because you gotta remember I
wasn't doing coke with people up there
no it wasn't me and I didn't have a coke
partner up there I had really one hidden
coke partner up there and that was it
I didn't want my secret to get out so I
had one guy who by mistake I saw at the
dealers one day and he goes I didn't
know you know but at that time the guy
was high up at the Comedy Store so we
never said no nobody but from time to
time I'd see him he'd give me a little
bump so actor but it's great or about
when no when I was at the store you know
chewy sold it there was nice you go
there Rick James would be there waiting
for chewy really and yeah he knew what
every great location on the Sunset Strip
of the storefront and you could hide
your coke behind the bar you don't have
to have it in your pocket somebody comes
they could give it to the bartender you
could put the coke on the tape I mean
what it it was the ultimate coke dealer
job chewy had I do not know it did make
any sense people would show up like it's
chewy here I'm like no and they're back
and then leave I'm like what you can
still stay like comics are like you can
still stay it's okay but I didn't know
like what they were there for it was so
weird because I got to the store and he
was rough on people he was rough on a
lot of people because he knew the the
nature of the comics you got to get into
a fun you know comics will [ __ ] with you
and him and Harris Pete would not take
[ __ ] from no comics not even a third
like you could not even tell them
anything they would [ __ ] who did they
did something like chewy crash
somebody's car on purpose
on purpose yeah he smacked the one comic
and the guy left and packed up and went
to Florida and became a realtor oh yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
there was no [ __ ] around to count me
the two dog guy dude he wouldn't let me
park there unless I brought him a
cheeseburger from McDonald's
it could be 1:15 in the morning to be
six cars in the lot and a lot that that
that has 60 people worth there'd be a
few cars now that heck I come in
any but I what do you got for me I had
to [ __ ] go get a cheeseburger to
McDonald's like here's your shakedown
I was an employee there those two
[ __ ] dog guys will [ __ ] in tyrants
the first time I met Harris I was
working the phones and I came down I saw
him and who was the Indian guy god no so
no younger one he open ferment see a
little bit later on long hair he was
like one of the upper regulars anyway I
said hi nice to meet you and he goes uh
nice to meet you in the Harrises I was
like oh I'm Ari I work upstairs
I put my hand out he just goes so he
walks away just like he would he was
bitter I love that his Pete me till I
was fun to go bitter with him he was
bitter and he would tell you I think I
was telling you guys yesterday that he
knew what he wanted you would say some
totally go it doesn't matter cuz in
three years I'm gonna be a Montana
anyway but he had a plan already he had
their date down he knew when he was
getting out of this [ __ ] on New
Year's he would host upstairs you would
put a ton of my works at midnight did
you ever see him dressed up it was funny
yeah I forgot about that
it was [ __ ] crazy to get him see him
driving the the county store staff was
different
they were good like right now I don't do
coke I'm done coking 12 [ __ ] years I
didn't even know cocaine existent
economy start I thought I had about a
year ago that
after 11:30 that's when the Freeth
karate stuff gone by Dean I'm saying I'm
gone by 11:00 11:15 but I hear you got a
commie store about 12:30 that place is
real that's yeah yeah after we stayed
till the end of time yeah no you stayed
I was telling Lee when you Whitman you
and I discuss you moving to New York I
remember saying to you it's a no-brainer
for a guy like you it doesn't make sense
because I could be up and I would go
home snort coke I would come down at
5:00 and call you yeah I fly and you
just be walking in yeah he called one
time he's just like I'd the phone rang
it was like I don't know five o'clock
something I think video games till the
Sun came up you sure hear the garbage
trucks first like [ __ ] I stayed up too
long these stay up for another hour
anyway he called and it wasn't like I
was in bed I was like pillow and he just
started laughing you're the only one I
knew would be awake right now I know
he's waking up if you're not gonna sleep
New York is the place for you oh really
gonna I'm the type of [ __ ] that
if it's midnight now in that way the
last 10 years going home four out of ten
I'll get in the car and go for a ride
because there is nowhere to go you just
go for a ride
Starbucks is open till midnight that's
it
but in New York I can get up at 1:00 in
the morning
still do two spots yeah exactly you
could do two spots after 1:00 in the
morning go get a steak you know you
can't sell any why when you said New
York I was like it's the real it's a
no-brainer so much fun because you take
advantage of what's there you're gonna
be out till 5:00 every morning if you're
not gonna be out no vibe
don't move to New York be a bush you're
smoking a cigar just smoking a joint and
walking around the streets I'll call my
West Coast friends then cuz they're you
know a little early and it's just like
should walk around and enjoy especially
like April to October
it's solely a moment I've been given
interviews to this guy he's trying to
put a book together who [ __ ] him I'm
better writer than him no no no this
guy's a great that's fine he's a great
often he's writing a book about you know
like he has all these great pictures of
architecture from the 80s in New York
and what the eighties were like in New
York and he goes our friends referred me
feet to youth is he's a podcast fan and
he said you know a lot of stuff because
if I sent you like just little things
with you and I go absolutely you know
are you ain't give me a credit in your
book because yeah absolutely you know so
we just talked about like CBGB's how I
snuck in there when I was 14 to see the
police Bruno I didn't even sneak in the
guy let me in the front door I had a
place that was so degenerate all the
stories of like Kevin Pollak and [ __ ]
uh what's-her-name Smith and all the
[ __ ] everything every artist every
musician was poor living down there
because it was heroin there and they put
on their uniforms to go work at TGI
Fridays uptown it's really how different
the city was CBGB's a [ __ ] high-end
clothing store now the village was a
complete different entity in New York in
the 70s you didn't go to the village you
went to Chinatown if you went to the
village it was because you were a little
weird you were concerned yeah you were
considered to be a little out there like
you know saying the village were is like
what people who were gluten-free we're
gonna do a village in the eighties you
know and heroin people people met up
that's what they met up it was
gluten-free people people thought there
was special in the village you know yeah
and then you had [ __ ] heroin in that
village so there was coolness mixed with
some cash yeah it was it was really I
don't know what our point was what the
[ __ ] were doubling back that's right if
you look at the marvelous miss Mazal
that was always like the back
than the what the village you know where
it was like oh cool Oh someone's getting
shot right ooh
you know they're like slumming it in a
hip way the village is white the only
time I get into it
for this place called Bleecker Bob's it
was my following my all-time favorite it
was it was amoeba but cheap you know I'm
saying you don't have me but record
store yes but when I was like kid it was
like [ __ ] a paradise you know like
you went to all me but you went to
whatever the [ __ ] I what I bleak a bog
give ups to lose your mind you would
find [ __ ] there that you didn't know
existed live show [ __ ] like that you
know the village wasn't really uh I mean
that's so good little sort of CBGB's
they say how old I was
let me say how old I am I was in the
village when she the son they have to
John Lennon got shot I still remember in
New York how [ __ ] backed it was what
do you mean like Paris mess
bumper-to-bumper [ __ ] people walking
from all boroughs from States people
everybody came in to go to Central Park
for john lennon memorial so instead of
me going that way heavy I said let me go
the other way they had a little park
down in the village that they were gonna
have a memorial on and I'm when I went
to the village I went the Bleecker Bob's
I wanted to have parkland I bought some
coke and they sold coke at that Park
when I was a kid it wasn't the best coke
in the world they did the trick and I
got a head shot down him down in the
village and I bought in those days like
a coke wallet like you opened this
wallet up and I had a bottle a razor
blade and a tutor and a little like a
shiny not please cigar ass cuz it
couldn't break it was like a piece of
stone yeah
so you had your own little coke kit and
your wallet only in 1980 you know the
only exhibit
exactly yeah the bowie exhibit had a
whole glass table full of coke spoons
what's that the David Bowie it was like
a David Bowie traveling museum I saw it
in like Melbourne and then somewhere
else to Brooklyn oh my god she's got a
whole tray of his coke spoons and
they're all beautiful he's had like 30
of them that is crazy his old coke
spoons yeah so close in this play how
many time I was got you a coke spoon
from Columbia I was there I always
picked you up one and my other buddy who
still does it all same my ashes they
sell coke swooned and Columbia still it
mostly tourists ship because they're
like probably here for cocaine it's like
but like only the tourist part it sounds
like a little spoon on top a little
bottle with a chain or just it's just I
know just like a little spoon probably
like the size of like yeah maybe like
your finger you know with just like it
looks like a salt spoon we're just
taking a couple pieces of salt there's
just like that big you know for little -
truce - truce
I used to have the unique Coke tool -
who made it who invented it it was a
double-barrel shotgun and it was a straw
but instead of right here it became two
straws and then one into your nose Wow
we were kids and they had that crazy
[ __ ] straw uh-huh crazy straws the
crazy straw you drink chocolate milk
then you had a stroke after that hit if
you see a kid with a fucked-up eye today
it's cuz he had a crazy straw and my
White Castle shake oh you're gonna be
sucked into your eye pops out kid if you
see somebody today with a fucked-up jaw
oh my it's because they drank a shaking
like that or it slowly get it up yeah
you got a card and you're like trying to
prove it to your parents and your
parents like I'm pong it's not gonna
work and you're like it's gonna work and
you're pulling you're pulling you know
you're dying that's the [ __ ] worse
anyway they had this [ __ ] coke straw
that was a piece of glass with two tubes
and at the end of the straw it was a
shovel all made from glass so you put it
in like you're parking your jacket you
opened up the baggie you put the straw
in then you put two things to your nose
anyway and you get both of them is
called double-barrel shotgun but when
you got [ __ ] up you put on your back
pocket you sat on it and then went the
neighborhood I must have sat on 20 of
those things I never got a stitch I'm
saying you throw them away the cops
never catch you the cops never caught
you in those days and then we got caught
with nothing I got caught with weed that
is it really that was it and then we got
caught anything
oh we're weed I got it out of the way
early I got arrested in January of 82
for weed in New York City and I got a
ticket and they made me go to court and
they gave me six months of that
probation that if you don't get in
trouble it doesn't stay on your record
mm-hmm and that was it Fred you've read
ha ha ha I mean I'm guessing gut sounds
right I don't know yeah that was an easy
I called the guy three times I swear to
God
I called the guy had to call him once a
month just to check in say I'm out doing
crimes how you doing how you doing Joey
good what do you do I got a job at
footlocker I'm living with my mother I'm
behaving myself all right call me next
month
have you had any car crap police contact
no I haven't alright thank you that was
it and then I moved to Colorado and I
called them and told them I was moving
and he goes just write me a letter and
make it official and you're out don't
worry
nothing he was a good pro bono that's
cool
you got good ones and you got bad ones
there's a probation officer walking
around but I guarantee that [ __ ]
still thinks of me and which one I get
him torture ha ha i tortured that guy on
principle I kept I would put chemicals
in my urine test to break the machine so
it could read anything for anybody for
the rest of the day it'd just be like a
little percentage or a little bit coke
then what's this because you know you
send them out you send them out the labs
then when the last test them that way
the [ __ ] this guy do because you could
throw [ __ ] in your pistol or ha ha but
they count as a hot urinalysis so you
got to be crazy to you gotta be a little
careful all right
he's opening up what do you think
brother I want an expert everyone's
comics what the pocket what they should
do I'm crazy
first of all I don't live I live by the
quarter but most importantly I lived by
the day right now I want you to tell me
your quarter project okay talking about
what do you see going on till September
September and before a baby York talked
about a I'll probably be in New York
probably no stand-up that probably be no
stand-up over which I don't understand
how is dinner gonna be stand-up over in
New York in [ __ ] June well they're
two we every step is two weeks so I read
today first step is like you know
necessities then is like real estate
type things then is restaurants and then
is like sporting events in my bed and
each one is two weeks in between so I
don't know there's the thing mid-june is
when they start step one early to mid
June so it's like August so really till
it gets like open open maybe you don't
go somewhere I don't [ __ ] know but if
I'm there I should be walking around
getting [ __ ] tuned up with friends we
should be doing hello Molly a little bit
of coke and then some like bunch of
booze and weed and stuff and having a
[ __ ]
great time my friend said it the best
Sal said it if s it's me the [ __ ]
Roaring Twenties
we're not gonna have anywhere to go with
the next day for about two months it's
gonna be insane
everyone's gonna be like just come over
to my place were having a house party
we're having eight people together and
then there's not you know that moment in
apartment someone's a card I got to go
home I got it and people were like why
just go sleep in the bed we'll start
[ __ ] partying again tomorrow
[ __ ] noon who cares nothing no one's
get anywhere to be right now yeah so as
soon as they say you can go over to your
friend's house which is like in a week
or two we're all going to friends houses
and we're not just gonna do that sober
hit this town is gonna get [ __ ] up
hard for like two months it's gonna be
on Joey
you're gonna wake up somebody's gonna
spray to join your mouth you all right
then back here you come to get your line
you look you know [ __ ] quarantine
coffee they're saying they're not
opening up Broadway to January 1st all
right
who cares who watch who wants to watch
you [ __ ] a man in tights singing a
song [ __ ] see Rigoletto and blazing is
[ __ ] but that Y is mightier and the
musical the [ __ ] movies aren't good
anymore the music's gonna be good what
are we gonna do with the Knicks their
band that we're sending them in Toronto
they having a good 25 years if [ __ ] if
there's no if there's no if there's no
without basketball no MBA no garden no
garden no garden Penn Station is gonna
be sort of open underneath it
every time to stab somebody Joey
get your [ __ ] get your get your dad
stopping women out come on down in New
York won't welcoming people who listen
to this show yeah you know yourselves do
you Simone all our friends except for
Rogan with the jackpot in the movie hot
pression you know better than ever yeah
yeah hit the jackpot in the middle of
the depression congratulate them up in
the air was a how am I gonna make ends
meet he's like I didn't even thinking
that way [ __ ] so you know I mean what
do you think about the road your safety
if you stay close you gonna fly them for
a while
I'm not gonna fly for a while I'm in no
rush attest this [ __ ] out people like
everybody says it's not that bad people
say it's worse I'm not looking to test
[ __ ] out what about i'ma drive
everywhere including if I go move
somewhere for a while I'm gonna drive
there make take a few days doesn't
matter
not any rush we're in a time of like you
can relax I've got a YouTube channel
started just doing [ __ ] you know just
getting [ __ ] going and having fun it's
been in town my parents or just going on
the road she's going on like a two-week
long road trip why not
you got nothing else going on so I'm
gonna do [ __ ] like that but if I can't
do stand-up I don't know I'm gonna go a
little nutty sticking over to Hong Kong
but now it's [ __ ] not that great
there it's good there for a long time
ari it's been great you were never
allowed to open it open it stand up clip
for a month already
Dave Wow the stand-up club there's but
open for a month
that's great let's total yeah that's
great going to a [ __ ] comedy club
that's a comedy club I want to work at
you know I'm saying where people die it
one thank you I can't read sarcasm I
think you're right no listen ever once
somebody the [ __ ] sand with Ari
Shaffir show and somebody breathed on me
and I got [ __ ] SARS and why I won't
work it was wasted in New York staple in
LA
what's that Hong Kong was safer than LA
and New York and Chicago Seattle anyway
I was Hong Kong we're safer who say are
you [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] story [ __ ] a Winnipeg and
you're like no don't go to Mexico City
the dog it's starting honking wind star
woman child one where's Hong Kong wait
wait showed my map open up a map Lee
where the [ __ ] is China and where the
[ __ ] is moving that's what I want to
know Hong Kong like China's [ __ ]
right in the middle right the [ __ ]
bong hole okay I don't know I've no idea
Hong Kong is a southern right tip at the
bottom right tip on the map
so it's like Gore from San Diego to LA
it's like a three-hour flight from
Beijing business it could be further it
could be further believe me alone in the
world I want you two hours from be dots
they're putting [ __ ] poses where are
you gonna guarantee McAdoo spots well I
don't know where besides well it depends
if you're in Baltimore and it's not
gonna open up in November when it gets
worse again we don't we don't know we
don't know dick let's just assume for
the next 90 [ __ ] days what is your
[ __ ] plan eventually things are gonna
open in three weeks you gotta get back
on stage it's a good process it's in
your blood
all right so you you pick three clubs so
I might move somewhere where they have
more stand-up we're in New York they
don't have it in New York why not
because New York City is starting phase
one in the [ __ ] early to mid June
they haven't met all the [ __ ] check
marks yet all right listen they're gonna
open a [ __ ] restaurant okay all right
no I'm in I'm in I'm in I'll not do
spots for a little while listen to lunch
which is the stand which is Gotham which
is all these things there's a bunch of
restaurants that that do comedy
I think quick yummy I do people come in
that does calm that's a local homeless
person he's just up there blathering
comedy club
that you understand me I think give me
one of those this is like what people
don't know like I've been talking a lot
of business owners and I don't you know
they call me we're friends and you know
I'm George and Jersey and I go you're
barking up the wrong tree if you're a
business owner right now instead of
crying every day and calling your
governor and bothering them when he
didn't open up my business I want you to
realistically look at your business yeah
sit down
get a [ __ ] measuring thing measure
seven feet
well it's six hump mention seven measure
seven buy a piece of Plexiglas put it on
top of your thing and you have to have a
written plan for that certain department
of health and they'll open you up I bet
that'd be great Plexiglas so everyone's
out there at a restaurant but you're all
behind Plexiglas you can be right there
and they serve you're through one of
those situations enclose it airtight
push through what you're gonna have is
you're gonna walk into a restaurant and
she's gonna come to you with a mask
uh-hum gloves and there's gonna be a
table in between you and the people next
to you and they're gonna take your order
doing it and then they're gonna throw
away their page the menu and then
they're gonna bring you whatever than
you eat and you pay with cash ATM and on
the way you have arrows on the floor and
it shows you how to social distance
that's it
I'm out - I'm not taking that chance I'm
not doing it what chance I'm not doing
that I'm not going to socially distant
restaurants when it's half-full and lame
okay well I know myself as I said it I
realize you've eaten monkey brains in
Thailand some [ __ ] both in Thai Leia
at this point you need a billy goat you
like John Rambo so I think I ate some
dog soup and Ernie's you're talking
about [ __ ] I'm not talking
I'm talking about what comedy clubs do
you see opening in New York because
they're a smaller ones I think okay like
so the stand the cellar
um New York Comedy Club the small ones
if you're a [ __ ] hundred cedar you
can already comply with like you know
you a question when we're gonna be dance
at the store when we first became
regulars and you went up at 12:30 how
many people were on stage that's what
mattered you said yeah I'm like people
on a stage one in stage on the audience
I'm gonna be the audio audience yeah
eight twelve yeah five nights four
nights a week to eight people following
Paul Maury be done once it could be done
again no is not gonna handle that
[ __ ] podcast comics the [ __ ] actor
comics the ones who were like oh I never
do that before why would I go up in
front of less in the theater it's like
you weren't gonna be able to handle that
[ __ ] spaced out room as a comic we
all engage we like and I get and we all
know what we want and we don't want to
do at the 10 o'clock show you're only
getting 30 people anyway it's not that
weird
we had shows cancelled in New York
[ __ ] six months ago because of nobody
came what was a prom in New York that
became in New York was you had to all
thing you had to in a comedy clubs yeah
and and 50 25 of them were really legit
the other ones are just [ __ ] dumps
now it's always they always got to good
comics everyone held up so this was Oh
New York became what every place else
became greedy you know oh I got for rich
people killed NYC yeah I got four walls
we could get a liquor license we don't
need a liquor license look what happened
in that way all these shitholes started
opening up to open mics which merry eyes
pay five hours to get on stage pay to
get on stage my rap shitty that was
[ __ ] demo that's complete [ __ ]
it's complete [ __ ] in a really time
they make you buy a drink I'd like well
I'm stealing glass you'd have to buy
West were broken so many your glasses
there was a time in New York we had to
bring five people here they call bringer
shows what bring her shows but for our
situation yeah right now 90 days yeah
when do you think you're gonna go back
to New York full-time about another
month I think maybe even less than that
and then I'd take a couple weeks and
then like hang out there for a little
bit go back to my stuff for like a month
or two feel it out you know it changes
and then maybe figure out another city
to live in or if if comedy clubs open
open again I would love to do it
in New York all I need is those twenty
thirty people ten how are they Jerry get
a minion how old you know 46 years old
how old how are you in the girlfriend
get on law it's [ __ ] great you know
okay so what's our 24/7 all right so let
me ask you a question how many nights a
week do you still want to go out and do
comedy seven still still in the five or
six I mean you got the girlfriend now
you're a little older I mean you don't
care okay
so line five at least eight nights on
out multiple spots every you wouldn't
consider staying where you're at now and
doing what you're doing in New York same
thing what do you mean I mean oh just
doing nothing you mean just like hanging
up yeah maybe for a little bit see a
friends that's good I haven't seen my
friends in a while
what friends which [ __ ] you oh yeah Jay
Rosen Karenin like a you know I've seen
my friends Norman and [ __ ] like I
haven't seen it you it's like a no I
would do that for a while and just hang
out with friends a long ones you know I
could I could be okay creatively with no
comics or would calmly yeah with no
comedy I could be okay I could shoot the
[ __ ] with your convenience you don't go
to Newport Little Walter there's comedy
you still I want to find nights a week
you stay close to you can to your family
to the calmly
it opens go go go I'm going nuts here
huh
I'm going nuts here a little bit you got
to do some social stuff no mushrooms
here's the fourth Knox Jewish just go
hang out are you dead
go ahead followers how much how fun is
he you know what I would do right now to
smoke a joint and go torture my dad I
[ __ ] go [ __ ] hell did I get a dog
for dinner sometimes oh yeah and they
don't even know they're like Oh Ahri's
being so fun today yeah yeah I don't
understand why you don't dose a move
give them like a 10 milligram and take
them for a walk and let them tell ya
don't give them a bird just give them a
leg up just give them like a little 5
milligram gummy bear just feeling just
wanna feel it and then let them loosen
up kind of good not boom then next you
know we'll send them away
we'll send them a capsule of that 125
milligrams straight for their to start
death let me tell you something your
father will walk is he still walking oh
yeah every day yeah yeah that's what
keeps those guys alive my Gran's crazy I
want to see my uncle Saturday with my
daughter 18 who he looks [ __ ] just
unbelievable five mostly some of these
people edit James I just looked up died
at 81 I was like oh wow I'm like wow I
mean she must've lived way harder than
my dad not a lot of drugs a lot of drugs
just not taking okay you know the road
yeah he's a killer knew a performer it's
precious know that Amy Winehouse
documentary you see it is it new or the
old one I think it's been the last
couple years yeah I watch it when I
first came on no it really was so
[ __ ] lame she just got on the road
and it was just like it wasn't even like
the Nirvana thing where it's like I oh
he was tortured it was just like she got
into coke and crack and heroin and then
she just kept doing it and then it was
all over it wasn't even like a response
to anything it was just like she just
got on the road and did got worn out and
did a bunch of crank and [ __ ] died
she was getting [ __ ]
yeah yeah she would have been cool the
party with shoes who I want to party
with in New York
who's the chick who was on one of those
ABC family shows or whatever she's
blonde she might have been Sabrina the
Teenage Witch or might have been
somebody else she's [ __ ] batshit
crazy now she got caught throwing a
[ __ ] bong out of her [ __ ] fifth
story window in New York the cops
knocked in the dork stirs party until
that she freaked out and took her bong
threw it under the street her glass bong
what's her name Lee nope no she's played
Sabrina it was the other it was the
other one right at the same time but
she's talking Amanda Bynes I want to
party with her just one night or two and
just be like let's have some fun let's
talk [ __ ] let's get [ __ ] up she knows
some [ __ ] secret spots in New York
for sure where you knock on a [ __ ] a
walk-in refrigerator and there's some
steps down to some cool Club she knows
all those spots I want to party with her
and whatever she puts in front of me am
I sure tonight's about me and Bynes e so
I'm a little lost
yeah that's the New York I want to do oh
[ __ ] what's that in the window it's the
sunlight and we're still drinking beers
you are on a different planet what's
going on you need what some socializing
we're doing wine we want to talk just
pick up the phone call somebody but it's
like you want to be there with somebody
where do you think there's no calming
the I've waited to walk around with Joe
DeRosa and get slices of pizza is not
open to users there's a there's a front
you know that look where you go to get a
speed slice that's on the street so you
don't to walk in the you know the window
service they have that for bars now you
can go get a [ __ ] mixed drink and
like see you later and walk on with it
like it was a [ __ ] smoothie from
Starbucks it's like you know in between
in LA in between New Year's Christmas
and New Year's and it's always like at
1/3 capacity you can find parking like
oh yeah this makes sense I like this
week that's a new it's gonna be just
[ __ ] rerun this city it's already
great it was already great do do you
know what it's like to be white in New
York they let you drink openly in the
street the worse they're gonna say is I
can come on put that in the trash can
you can do whatever you want it's
amazing it's gonna be right back
together they're gonna enforce a law the
[ __ ] your grandmother died yesterday
[ __ ] get out of here I'm just drinking I
think they thin the herd New York dog a
la manager it's it's gonna be a lot of
people left New York they they're done
with buildings Lee said he went for a
walk dear day which the IRA all leave
you know image Steve Simone Steve's a
liar one's a godless liar he gets to my
house twice a week in the mail it's a
pound one day I can only walk to
Starbucks and walk but he said he saw
four moving trucks on the walk so
between here and there
people are abandoning [ __ ] ship Jack
people want to get out of buildings so
they'll send to her and it's funny I've
been watching a lot of old New York
movies you know looking at the streets
the extras how they would do New York
just grew exponentially that area the
population in that area you know I
wonder what it was an 82 to was no more
so holy I can't have that because rich
people like I need to be
it keeps pushing shouts it's it's too
much good it'll go mad it'll get back to
it we have new generation of Momo's
though I have a vaccine but like how
many people can afford to send their kid
to get an apartment where they're at NYU
it's like you know I mean it's like look
I can still afford to send you there but
we're 40 minute drive I can't afford
another 30 grand a year to put you up in
my apartment
you drive it's gonna be rough you'll
know that those are empty it's gonna
bring everything down it's gonna bring
[ __ ] drugs up it's gonna be way cool
again a little violence too little
violence we'll be back
it's worth it it'll be cool looking
there anyway that's what I'll do for a
few months and then who knows who the
[ __ ] knows I'm like you I'm living the
now I'm enjoying myself having a great
time started a podcast channel like I
said you to.com slash skeptic tank
[ __ ] pushing into there teach yoga
I don't know how fun I walk my dog I
spent time my dog every day a week ago
here what's the teaching yoga I won't
have been involved with yoga well Joey
I've been enlightened I would say for a
long time I have friends that have been
to India some multiple times okay so
when you talk about enlightenment you
really can't have that conversation
without thinking about me and yoga is
not just a way to work out it's also a
way of life
Joey it's about getting your mind and
your body straight so what I do is I get
some [ __ ] booze or joint and I
[ __ ] do yoga I'm a yogi I do legit
classes but you know as best as I you
know that it are you sort of find
everything yeah I'm certified in every
[ __ ] Akrid ation there is well
certified I have friends that have been
to India Joey you're not hearing me some
multiple times listen where I get my
lottery tickets he's from India listen I
can't
that doesn't mean I'm a lot of fun I'm a
yoga teacher how many moves do you have
Oh watch this right now have a pattern
look at that touching right
no that's like stability that's great
that's great I mean do you have a flow
there that is just [ __ ] sitting there
being thankful do we open up with a
namaste is there a bong do we sometimes
there's a bond look if I was home you're
balling hazel a gong you [ __ ] you got in
a gun do you do the Breath of Fire these
are the questions I'm asking you I'm
gonna know I have a a sapphire what's
the Breath of Fire let the fires
but [ __ ] that you sit there
yeah palms out the best teacher for
Breath of Fire is on Sunset and Laurel
Canyon yeah Laurel can do those are
student so much that's a Lauren they're
not [ __ ] student to yours yeah I know
what you're talking about thats called
that's a done Delaney ogle with the
Kundalini yeah yeah then there's the
other one that my wife goes to I used to
go with it
alright so that's how you became a yoga
teacher you got [ __ ] Enlai probably
got like 12 minutes and moves in about
30 minutes of people are the nicest
people in the world they got a little
body funk to them we are but besides
that they're really nice nice people
they try that they don't clean the mat
you know but clean the mat there's a
little at the wire there's a cute little
yoga teacher there well that first moved
up there me and my wife used to go up
there on Tuesday nights for date night
this is way before the birth of my
daughter this is 10 years ago every
Tuesday my wife would get home we change
and we'd run to the Y and we do 6:00 to
7:30 yoga we need dinner at NoHo and
then we'd run home and watch sons of
anarchy and that was our date night and
then we go again Saturdays at 11:30 this
is even before the podcast this is 1010
that was our system I wasn't really
going on the road me you and Rogin
whenever Rosen would take us out we
weren't really going on the road and to
town ahead it doesn't end no no so it's
good day tonight though
yeah Yoga for date night is one of the
best thing
I had this whole studio it's gonna do it
there I was gonna do it in era invite
friends over to do yoga just [ __ ]
comics trying their best you know if I
could do it downward dog I'm sure you're
kind of stuff I could do I do we'll do
one together with a Manilla yoga at the
end of my workout how dude stretch it
out I'll do a cat cat pose that post
I've heard of that cat pose I'll do a
child pose I don't know that one I'll
switch it up into the one where you lift
the arm and lift up the opposite leg oh
yeah for sure okay I do the one where
you take your leg and throw behind you
I do the standing one the warrior I do
this one I do the tree pose for balance
it's not the girl one wife's are gonna
be good no I never honest I never do the
goddess but I've always been very
intrigued with that aspect because when
I got out of the [ __ ] joint what are
you doing re yeah - that's great that's
a good one right there never do this I
call this one picked up the corner way
down and then you don't want to see you
because you're a Jew but there's a
quarter down there I got all these moves
yoga's fun do people actually watch this
do they pay you
yeah thousands now they're just watching
this makes them do [ __ ] yoga I make
it accessible I say real terms
why don't you know what I gotta say just
take the [ __ ] online class me and
Bratz Bert Kreischer we're on uh we just
finished that sober October 30 days of
yoga fifteen days of hot yoga
and the day after we were one of the
Joker's crews with Sal and uh the people
there the [ __ ] cruise lines are cool
they do a bunch of comedy stuff and they
go we go me and Burt were like hey let's
teach her yoga class on the deck we know
all the moves by heart we just finished
on 15 of them in 30 days you know hey
there he goes uh and he goes um yeah so
we would love it so we just did it drunk
on the [ __ ] deck and every time I
would do this thing every time nothing
you're like hold hold you know and
release but instead of release I'll just
go and [ __ ] it okay next this fun with
you on the deck of the [ __ ] cruise
ship in the middle of the Atlantic how
many people there take him in class 75
80 maybe a hundred it was great we just
got drunk people kept bringing Burt
shots and then I'm like all I'm doing
this let's [ __ ] into a class so let me
ask you some is there somewhere in your
heart you thinking of dosing bird a
second time
sure multiple plans I got my mistake was
not getting his wife that way she got
upset at me because she felt left out I
think that was the biggest issue that's
the opportunity run say something no no
Mike owes him again they would be
[ __ ] hilarious like in a bar in New
York if you got on the fender priceless
there was a you know when I really got
into when I really got my hand [ __ ] up
on blow yeah there was two clubs and
there were friends with each other
yeah one was in Houston the motors in
Beaumont and it was Pete you remember
Pete and Slade Texas Pete yeah and Slade
have and I loved them both but I love
cocaine venom and you know then the week
always started different sometimes I
would go to Houston and just do Houston
but sometimes I would go to hee
and do Houston Friday and Saturday but
do Beaumont on Thursday and then I would
do weekends so I would switch it around
there are two clubs you could do either
of them either weekend so I'm getting
[ __ ] up hard its 2006 and I am just a
mess yeah those days it was you didn't
know it was whatever happened the night
before
is he gonna show up we just oh yeah
that's how ideas that Joey Diaz was
that's got me on the road Joe Rogan only
need one opener I take his one opener
but he was like well I might not have
the one opener I don't know till I get
to the airport if Joey's gonna meet me
at the airport it was crazy
it was pre cell phone to so you could
someone fep smartphone but he was not
answering I could be drivin for a reason
I mean nobody hey Joey
we'd have to call for your spots yeah
like hey this this is the Comedy Store
can you please call back and get your
spots yeah I used to have a pager that's
why that's nobody would call me and he
said he said he would show up and he
would call like where are you and you're
like I don't know I'm not coming at the
airport that shows tonight what do you
mean I can't get somebody down to the
airport right now it's like that we were
boarding in 20 minutes so you start
bringing me in case Joey didn't come smc
or I'd made a lift joy didn't come how
[ __ ] crazy is that and that's how you
know why are you the response was let me
get another employee to cover up this
employee instead of just firing and if
anybody else was to do coke around him
tell her how pissed he would get he
hated it he tolerated me just I don't
know why he loved me I think he thought
you were crazy
I still remember quantum lion I am the
meconium one morning at 6:00 in the
morning waking him up like hello and I'm
like hey I'm not going he's like why not
like because I'm like
by my wallet what are you talking about
I find my wallet and then remember the
new years I didn't show here was that
you and Duncan with and you're like
talking and you don't like you again yes
Diaz ain't coming them Romans like
that's great that he told you guys we
didn't tell me I don't even call rogue I
just decide not to even go that's how
good the guys The Wiltern dog it was so
bad people wouldn't hire me beep it's
not like it's not like he got drunk and
wasn't as good as you could be he was a
complete zero because he wasn't there
you can't do any worse than not they're
not there oh my god he's not gonna learn
a lesson if he never gets recompose like
a comeuppance people don't know lessons
without comeuppance he would you like
okay well you're on next week Rogan
would talk to me and asked me if I was
okay and I tell him yes and then I would
show up imagine if you call a job and
say I'm not coming like what was the
situation
alright so Pete he was my friend yeah
sorry yeah waiting for Thursday and sure
enough I get high till [ __ ] 5:00 in
the morning I got a checks out 7 a.m.
flight
now I'm getting anxiety I'm not going
I'm not going
I still got a gram of coke left I can't
leave so that that was one time that
remember those days where you had
Wednesday and Thursday then you had the
weekend yeah so the first time I got
Pete was like all right I'll see you
Tuesday didn't show up Tuesday had an
audition then Wednesday came along and I
said man I missed the flight and the
other one is packed
ok you get somebody to cover for you on
Wednesday night so now you at least you
know [ __ ] it Wednesday night I go out
and get [ __ ] I got am I gonna play
like what do you talk about you have a
night leaving and him and me calling him
and going I'm leaving for the
important hanging up and I wouldn't go
anywhere and next thing you know my
pager would start blowing up at like it
was nuts like if the plane was supposed
to land at one o'clock in the Houston
and that's three o'clock you know my
phone my pager at home which start
blowing up but I'd be passed out I
thinking that South from doing blow and
the paid you would wake me up and I wake
up and they're like like sixteen make
the mix that mix whatever and then I
would call them back I think this was
why the call back yes he's like he had a
pre feel he had a cell phone I held out
till the end everybody had a cell phone
first here cell phone you could hang up
in a shoulder strap yeah and hang it up
I held out to the end to get his cell
phone and so I remember calling Pete
he's like where the [ __ ] are you and I'm
like I'm here my plane just landed I'll
meet you outside I'm in gable and him
keep calling me like where are you and
me calling him back on I'm wrong gate
six
no like where are you hoping this would
go at this point like he's gonna find
out he was still in bed it was crazy it
was and I would just stop answering the
phone calls from all over from Ralphie
from [ __ ] cuz he's gone where are you
here I and then they [ __ ] just
finally realized I wasn't coming so I
look about six months later Slade ham
calls me and he goes can you work the
weekend I'm like absolutely and he calls
because guess what I got this weekend
Joe Diaz he just bro you better get a
backup that he's not gonna show slaves
like this is my brother he's not gonna
do that to me
sure enough that Thursday night I went
out have [ __ ] up and I had a cuz he
was my I felt so bad because he was my
buddy I had that kept keep calling back
I just landed but I'm in the air time
hold on wait for me I just took part in
uh-huh and you're still partying in LA
you're not I would still be out that way
but you didn't do coke in the daytime so
you just be sober just sitting there
like I got a battery back all right
by that time Jewish do you want pause I
don't know but by that time I would be
down but I would feel so bad about
myself I couldn't I wouldn't be able to
sleep but I would feel so bad about that
I had that I had stayed up all night and
done coke and now I'm missing this date
I did that a couple times to people like
if they want an improv or like a regular
book that are your chances were even
less and if you sent me a deposit you
definitely not going to see me shows in
LA like if there's someone hired you to
do a bar show or like a something around
la woody today let's say for some weird
reason I didn't have a spot at the store
and I'd had three shows the first show
paid me 50 the second show paid me a
hundred and the third show paid me 45
hours that 45 hour show had a 50/50 shot
of me showing up because I already had
the hundred the quarter what if I bumped
into the man before I had that I'm not
making a factor it would be very rare
unless I needed weed or something I
would it my life was horrible
my luck my comedy career was controlled
by cocaine I would never be where I'd be
today if I was still doing coke it could
not have nuts
because you always talked about how like
you were out every night this is man oh
yeah a bad cokehead Oh Joey I'm since
I've met you I didn't know what it was
when you were doing it but I said much I
met a bunch of people who do coke all
the time and it just your symptoms
didn't look like Coke you weren't a
backhoe kid you wouldn't get you a straw
I took care of business first yeah
business
was first you want your left you wanted
to walk you can do all the coke you want
I will never get angry and I need before
doing Coakley you tell me you like coke
you like the [ __ ] whatever I don't care
but as long as you're here at 7:00 a.m.
you know who as long as you take care of
what you have to take care of like I
wasn't canceled at the store in those
days because that's like business you
gotta do that was my business you all
the can't sell broker because he
wouldn't fire you or were taking care
but I had to work for myself I was doing
it I was canceled on Rogan and I was
canceling on comedy clubs on my own self
yeah you know you know Rogan remember
when I stopped working Sunday's now we
just get up on Sunday and leave just
gone and he would get mad at me because
I was trying to make a point we're not
working Sundays no more if you book the
Sunday you book Sunday I got a family
and I didn't have a family I just had a
girlfriend I have some type of family
normally in my they did not want to work
Sundays I did not want to work Sunday so
I stopped work on Sundays I like getting
back on Sundays for potluck but the
stores but I could do my spot to ya know
was all I come on let's let's leave
Sunday I can do a spot at the store and
he Rogan say kiss he would take us to
Phoenix Friday Saturday and Sunday and
Wow one of those Florida clubs
oh yeah but Austin also Austin was a
Sunday awesome was a Sunday - I think he
switched to Thursday eventually switched
to Thursday oh yeah cuz once he had the
kids I talked him out of it I'm like I'm
not doing Sundays and I still remember
leaving him somewhere like just not just
any of my openers we're like we're like
now I left I'd be like what I might even
have some respect for it but I'm like
I'd be like no I mean I'm never gonna
work with you again
I can't I needed somebody there and
[ __ ] I'm a local
here's the deal
in 1999 I woke up one Sunday in Dallas I
was working the addison improv and I was
working with my idol licked Apollo and I
woke up that [ __ ] Sunday and I said
what the [ __ ] am I doing here
honest to god I was like this is like
beyond like I thought
I've told Lee because of I don't mean
that and you know more than anybody what
I'm talking about what you know I have a
very very very very very big religious
background yeah and I really believe in
Sundays is the Lord there there's no
what's why you don't work Sundays
there's no work on Sonny no I'll tell
you what my thing is re okay I believe
that especially in the comedy that we
have in the business that we're in there
has to always be some type of normality
if not we forget who we are you know
when when you go home well no I agree
with that I agree with that
you need a movie night that's really we
we had you know I am so good Joe Rhodan
got that spotify deal because there is a
God because if anybody knows Joe Rogan's
generosity is you and I and how he took
care of us and how we wouldn't be here
today if it wasn't for Joe Joe opened up
a door for us and we ran through it you
follow him saying here [ __ ] him and then
we made my money and what happens yeah I
mean you have to really think about God
Joe deserves
Joe bought me more steaks than my own
mother bought me I sometimes would be
like it'd be like it'd be like I was
gonna sandwich the subway but there's a
fogger to challenge there was no I still
remember walking out of a fog loaded
child with you in in Texas where he
bought us is shot
and this is 15 years ago oh yeah it was
like $150 shot of whiskey apiece as a
[ __ ] digestif he added yeah as an
aperitif the truck that goes by he just
called the lady over and he goes do him
a favor give him a shot of the best
whiskey you got and when he got the
thing is like Jesus Christ it was for 50
a shot I mean that's how generous Joe
has been to me when um I talked I talked
about this on this podcast Monday that's
why as a comet you have to be happy when
other comics elevate your now you're
gonna grow if you throw hate on Pete
when he got that deal because he's
friends with Davidson excuse and some
places got a deal because they work hard
can't somebody just get rewarded shut
the [ __ ] up
you don't say that he built the biggest
thing in the world so shut the [ __ ] up
but if anybody knows I mean he took
great cameras on the road
absolutely.we 88 what he'd read we went
nuts I never ate so good oh my god you
give me your first-class ticket remember
you go and you sit in first class
because I'm just gonna sleep I'm not a
respect for my elders yeah miss my boys
give me his first-class seat with Rogan
I mean we had no no no no he would
always always get one first-class ticket
next one to sit with him which often
stuff it was or the UFC will get him and
one companion ticket what comes to those
ability first class so if he flew a
third person he's like I'm up I'm not
spinning the [ __ ] $1,100 flight I'll
spend 100 and you know what a lot of
times he's bid I don't know how I'm
gonna forget time one time we did
Rascals in Orange New Jersey on the way
home we walk we were involved with a
comedic conversation yeah I mean I have
nothing in common besides comedy when
Joe and I talk comedy that's why he
loves me
because he knows the respect and the
dedication and I was a thief that never
stole a joke you know man I'm a feeder
that never stole a joke if anyone would
steal a be you because I believe this
religion so much I believe people that
are like oh you're just a real comic you
just talk comedy theory you could just
get into it and talk and it's like you
almost at any level it's like oh yes was
a real comedian was interested in theory
and you start talking about the pause
that hit that hook on that break when he
thinks that point when you start talking
something and I know that they know
comedy that much that's it one to a
different level now you're not telling
me that you saw what's-his-name special
on Netflix and it was great it was
amazing tell me that you just say words
I was amazed when you tell me that you
must how do you live in that town still
when you tell me that you saw the Bob
Newhart oh the album I have here yeah
when you when you quote me a line from
that and say to me the way he said it
the the Bob Newhart has a bit about
defending Abe Lincoln at the
proclamation it's a it's the weirdest
joke you've ever heard I'm not giving it
any justice my point mean when you find
somebody like that that you connect with
and a calming level that's why Joe and I
get along because show knows the respect
I have for this whole thing of ours this
thing's to me is a motorcycle game these
guys don't act like it because we've
become other things but tell me I lost
there I didn't become a comic to be a
[ __ ] whatever I became a comic to be
an outlaw okay I'm an outline so we
really like the whatever yeah you wanted
to blend in with people you want to be
invited to rich Hollywood parties this
is why I don't want to do that
it's not even the money it's it's that
they all like it's weird you in LA you
get this thing where they can't even
make fun of actors because someone might
know someone who knows them and like
well I thought I can't make fun of a
movie but it's like are you guys just I
don't know Emily lost its bite ya know
it's a different thing but Rogan got
woody but yeah some comics just don't
know for sure one was but no you know
what's great about Rogan helpful how
much he spent on us he was making less
than you are now on the road you know
him he might have had like I guess at
some point it the [ __ ] game show
money but like still it wasn't like he
was like super rich he was just like
doing well but like he would just throw
money around I think some weekends we
made more than him yeah he was a real
I've done a map he would take care of us
so much than the the comedy free to me
gave you you know comedy it was far let
me take one of the best things you could
do as a child as a child is to go away
for a week to a camp that specializes in
something like giving a little
basketball camp or a football camp or
something to investment camp
you went to an investment camp what
would you go no no it's a sleep wake you
Jewish tip but it's really weird because
it's it's seven days that's nothing but
that sport right Oh basketball camp no
I've done that a script yeah so yeah
when we used to go out with Rogen when
it was me you Duncan read Duncan Eddie
Eddie and today it was put in one so
well Tom it was pretty much two things
going on there there was a comedy camp
and a jujitsu camp
no okay the comedy camp we were learning
was it's it's hard to believe like I
wish we could do we could call that a
tour
calmly camp because that's what it was
yeah we were all on the same floor you
know but what was that lady eating and
[ __ ] down lady
shoulda said you saw him you know I go
to a rogue and they eat at 2:00 in the
morning and then I Drive home he tell me
how I have to lose weight and why'd you
take me for the morning steak city you
go into the city it never ends whatever
and you don't worry just one dish he's
like I'm gonna get three three and then
pick out of that and you won't have to
dessert yeah and then it's all done if
he pays the tab at the thousands you I'm
the way I could go hug you to go you
gotta start losing weight a chopped
salad I thanked him a lot and I thank
you because we learned a lot from each
other and that and guess what
that's never gonna happen again in this
lifetime it was so weird is going on the
road with two crazy good comics and it
was like just seeing the situation's
done that was we didn't have the whole
room there for Rogan he had a lot of the
room there for him but a lot of them was
just there for Saturday night out with
their friends and so he had to deal with
some [ __ ] rowdy people and it was
like watching you guys deal with it was
like wow that's a cool way to do it oh
that's a cool way to do it or make
friends with Homer it was actually got
my comic so late at night - what seemed
like Mooney deal with a heckler or any
of you guys or how to go hard or I don't
know it's just like it is I comedy
camera just sit in the back and just
[ __ ] watch and then talk about should
I assume I'm gone with Rogan to New York
with Duncan and Town Duncan that I was
get them lined up that night with the
chinks in Chinatown to get him a shot of
opium I'm gonna go get our feet rubbed
and [ __ ] right so our goal was to get
rid of Rogan so we get to the airport we
get to New York you know Rogan wants to
go out right away then he wants to go to
pool you know yeah I'm starting to feel
fine and all this [ __ ] and how many
doctors look like me like let's go
Chinatown let's go yeah I kept making up
this story to mr. auger we're never
gonna get opium Oh
we were trying to put Logan home you
know this way you could sew him like a
sneak out and go get the [ __ ] opium
Grogan's wouldn't stop he kept [ __ ]
shooting [ __ ] eight-ball and we ended
up go we ended up getting home like a 2
and I wasn't in my hotel room 10 minutes
Duncan's [ __ ] calling me like are we
gonna go down hang at the opium I'm like
are you [ __ ] serious you really want
to go to church like he really wanted to
go you know that scene once upon a time
in America yeah noodles De Niro would go
to the opium den oh yeah town and just
look so cool it was like a Chinese teen
and the guy would give you massages [ __ ]
that's what he wanted to go we had to
wait till Rogen went to sleep I mean
that it's [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] man that's
funny that's funny when he doesn't even
want do some things me and red band
whites we stop puppies at a puppy store
you know and Brogan's like he knew about
it then before us he was like that's a
puppy mill they're [ __ ] all the dogs
are inbred or whatever he was like I
can't I can't they're in cages they
should just whatever and we were going
in he's like no no don't I can't and
we're like [ __ ] off we're gonna play the
puppies
that's what time we're not gonna get us
and we were just like in there but you
can't resist puppies that was the only
time I was like yeah dude I'm doing my
thing it was always fun though it was
always fun [ __ ] crazy late-night
Italian dinners and pool and drinks yeah
you never touched your wallet at all god
damn it was fun you never touched a
wallet it's uh you know I
hate when I read negative [ __ ] about him
online and I just want all stop writing
that much I wanna I wanna I want to tell
people you have no idea yeah you really
have no idea what you takin a seven
bottom and I don't leave much popularity
[ __ ] whenever people say [ __ ] about him
sometimes you know I really want to give
him a them a laundry list of things that
he's good stuff he's done too for people
that nobody knows about that nobody even
has a clue but I love when they call him
a racist I love it I love it I love it I
love Who cuz I'm a racist person yeah
they say he's races people are crazy
this country they did a thing like they
somebody put up somebody sent me a
[ __ ] the email that the percentages of
people he had all his guests and I'm
like how does this affect your life
oh yeah it's nuts you know she's like
well he doesn't put percentage of
african-american women like yo somebody
who sent me a chart you guys haven't
done anything yet miss Pat's the only
one he viewed um talling and she's on
multiple times so the rest of us long
enough get to work and woman well I
think he's have Tiffany Haddish on he
loves me that Jamie all I think but they
[ __ ] one more percentage of [ __ ] and
what I understand is why get your
attention behind something you don't
like rather than just try to go build up
a [ __ ] this is what somebody when we
did my show the first year it was just
on the internet and somebody wrote a
blog and it said this is not happening
had zero women on and that's ridiculous
and then my manager who was producing it
a woman wrote that person back and said
we had seven women on we had seven women
on not zero seven and she goes well
still wasn't quite enough and then she
goes why don't you spend your time
promoting women we got miss Pat we found
miss Pat in [ __ ] the middle of the
Indianapolis once your time spent some
time writing about how great she is
instead of doing this negative American
thing like I don't like this and I don't
like this like then go do something
about it prop up a [ __ ] female
what are you [ __ ] on row because he
doesn't book enough with it go prop
somebody up well complain about what's
not running the right way
he's getting hurt by him booking [ __ ]
Elon Musk or then you start a [ __ ]
billion dollar company he'll have you on
Black Jacks
sort of billion dollar company I
guarantee you'll have you on run a
double marathon in two in a row and then
[ __ ] kill a deer he'll have yard [ __ ]
nut it's always a pleasure to have you
on Monday morning we're recording
yeah we're recording what the [ __ ] just
me and you talking talking about you
can't hear any of that I said some
terrible things
who the [ __ ] anymore were they gonna
cancel you were here at Louie's joke
about it was they said something
offensive goes what do you do next take
what my birthday yeah you already took
away everything I can't wait to get back
to LA and hang out you know it's so
weird how let's let's do musical chairs
with drugs one tired people dying and
they're still talking about canceled
culture go [ __ ] yourself that's when you
know we're all okay if you're not some
[ __ ] like that then we're okay as a
group I don't give two [ __ ] about
weapons nobody's danger I'm excited that
we may be in a lot where people start
going like I didn't like that I don't
like that like on comments everyone else
just respond with like hey dude we're
not doing that anymore
just well have like 50 comments back now
that we're not doing that anymore I'm
Armenian now hey we're not doing that
I'm pretty excited that they might we'll
find out today if I get Brand X tweaked
Ryan next week I'm supposed to do
Governors in July but they said it's a
quarter capacitors day this Thursday
coming
what how being [ __ ] Brad I'd be
amazing I'd be coming to get up again
[ __ ] listen there's I feel bad
because it's the only thing I really
miss what's that it's getting up at the
socialization is tough I don't like did
not getting a problem
two years ago you wanted me to put you
on an island he didn't want to call
nobody back you want to get off the
internet
now you wanted Johnny social go [ __ ]
yourself all right now you wanna be
plugged in it's been three months now
you wanna be [ __ ] society now you
wanna be the check boat what's it what's
a Julie McCoy that chick on The Love
Boat got used to greet anybody yeah no
student ran the joint but Julie McCoy
was a chick who when she came on she
always had ideas tomorrow
never in Chara was armed with the
[ __ ] crazy hand he was on like seven
times three years ago you done with
social media now you wanna meet people
get the [ __ ] out of here
they got anybody who's got cold food you
got a shave and I brought I'm telling
you so I know I'm not doing business
with you this is gonna turn into Mad Max
pretty soon they got a che and DeRosa
both had it yeah they gotta shoot a
little [ __ ] thing here Michael yo had
it a couple people had it my heart goes
out to them
this has been a [ __ ] horrible time
for a lot of good [ __ ] people and I'm
happy about it
we could [ __ ] bring some joy their
lives on a Monday morning [ __ ]
yeah a lot of those people who died and
from kovat were we're the opposite party
from whatever you're listening to it's
party so it was okay listen
god forbid I don't have a poor death but
what people what they forget to tell you
is and this isn't you know what man you
ever see some I saw my uncle to your
days 82 Ari he looks like a million
bucks but that's because Lea walks five
miles a day and that's because he he
hits a boxing bag 30 minutes I read that
that's Brett and he's still [ __ ]
sucks
he [ __ ] the 40 year old every Thursday
and you know you there's a way to be an
old man your father just went to [ __ ]
Kilimanjaro ever sorry and walked it you
know there's what we talking about how
great old people are how great old
people I forgot what the [ __ ] I was
going to say we just got to give him
some cash so they can [ __ ] order free
delivery groceries
people die from Colvard what I'm kind of
saying no you what about the people that
are born during coconuts they never
mention that must a lot of these people
that died during colbrunn what halfway
there already that's a sight then they
were halfway there already
Kovac took what little system they had
and destroyed it you know it really what
was the average age 81 I don't know I
don't have the facts I'm not a
scientific guy I just know a lot of
unnecessary death game whether it's true
forth whatever it doesn't matter how
much I'm back then and we're coming back
and that's all we've you know they have
a number they have a number of how much
each life is worth so like if they raise
the speed limit five miles an hour
though like that'll probably mean like
seven estra deaths a year and so they go
okay let's weigh that against how much
better it is for the economy to get
people to work five you know five
minutes faster and that number they've
always come up with is like is this
safety measure worth it's ten million
dollars per human life that's about the
number they decide is this much lost the
economy ten million that's one life
that's break even if it's 10 million $1
we can we can lose one person and I
think they're not even looking now if
it's like more or less than that but
that's how much of human life comes down
to at some point you got to get on we
need that cash that's the way in the
world that's a [ __ ] cold reality the
world and people like look it sucks it
sucks they always want to say that but
it's like we're putting you out to
pasture because we got to get back
that's alright they already had that
system ten million dollars you know what
I already had a good time I did some
time I made a few movies I'd have to do
some spots at the store yeah I got my
the other day it's our joy this life has
been pretty [ __ ] good you know what
man it's been good to me so far I mean
from here on in like I was telling my
friend yeah I can't believe it's almost
still [ __ ] alive I still can't
believe it but guess what Keith Richards
is alive Ozzy Osbourne still alive and
kicking and I'm gonna keep going being
the VIP buddy buddy good to me
yep I'm gonna keep I got my bicycle my
mountain bike what yeah you could've
come skiing with me next next winter
norm there's no
oh it's apo snowboarding sorry I know
how rad use retinol there's no
snowboarding at my age those days jumps
you just [ __ ] lost your hand you're
like a half a [ __ ] what ski five days do
you not a single break a couple Falls
you're [ __ ] lunatic I love you
[ __ ]
we have no choice we got no dates but I
got dates this weekend hopefully so
we'll know can I say someone think that
I did start a YouTube channel
youtube.com slash skeptic tank Joey Diaz
is on there I'm doing live actual video
podcast now just like you're seeing this
so go check it out and and yoga and and
[ __ ] other podcast - okay you know
dangly form hey they always ask about
you they were asking about your daughter
the other day like how old is she
it's fabulous she's got the thing in
your father sent me on her wall what the
thing you rube you rub during Passover
for good luck a mezuzah
mrs. Azusa she that's right so the Zhu
Zhu Pets writes in her room she loves
forgot he sent you that and then she
read all about it she did a whole you
know prayer that's in there she hear o
Israel I am the Lord I don't hear beat
about it she loved it and I'll continue
with CBD line I'm trying to get him on
for you oh yeah dude that [ __ ]
topical CBD is like a legit real helper
for my muscles unbelievable
you spread right into the muscle that's
what I swear by how does I loved that
dog I've been telling these
[ __ ] that that the CBD lying
cream has changed my [ __ ] life cuz
you know if you're going a long walk you
know sometimes like towards the end it's
gonna start getting sore so halfway
through just spread some in will you
know it's gonna get sore and then when
you get back to some more it's it's
great and it's legal bro I don't I don't
leave the house with everything my knees
I rub them on my thighs my we show the
camera how better my legs my legs used
to always be dry and [ __ ] no matter how
much your legs
culture oh yeah those are [ __ ]
whatever pose sit down before you break
an ankle
yogi I love you yogi yogi yogi re
Stan thank you for coming on today yeah
of course [ __ ] I hope you enjoyed
that little tape today with Ari like I
said he's a good man he's made mistakes
who hasn't he have made no mistakes you
know I'm saying go [ __ ] yourself spark
up another [ __ ] joint out of respect
for you [ __ ] but listening
today on a Wednesday but paying
attention mm-hmm well my daughter she's
a little girl so when she eats you go
she makes noises [ __ ] I don't make
noises when I smoke reefer this is my
world we goes you makes this noises like
you're drinking a strawberry milkshake
or something This Is It this is my world
this is all you need right here this has
been my world since I was [ __ ] 12
this will keeps me sane this is what
keeps me [ __ ] active this is my
failure beside Buddha beside [ __ ]
Allah beside God this is my number to
save you and Superbad the cat I missed
that [ __ ] all my life anyway I
hope you enjoyed the re-interview I've
had you long enough today you know I
love you [ __ ] with all my heart
and stuff keep your doors closed be
vigilant you know you know the [ __ ]
church rules [ __ ] keep your eyes
open keep your mouth shut you he is wide
open and that's all you need to know and
the heart is what it's all about if
you're angry if you mad check your heart
write it out and work on it you know I
don't know how it work for me but it did
I don't question my cocaine anymore I
don't question anything it's a higher
power and you gotta tap into it alright
I'm happy you enjoyed the podcast today
and Monday's podcast and that's it and
that's that before we leave though it's
time listen we're [ __ ] in quarantine
now six o'clock you gotta have the best
dick you've ever had right now you're
serving up the best day you're like
reoccurs Ruth's Chris you're the rules
Chris a dick right now because there's
nothing to do
you gonna watch the Ozarks how many
times you're gonna watch the Jodl i-ight
me tell you how many times can you watch
[ __ ] wheel of fortune and [ __ ] all
these other shitty [ __ ] shows on TV
this time you gotta look at mom and say
you know what the kids asleep let me
give you a stab but now I got you
covered because sometimes it's late at
night you dick ain't workin you get a
little old
you know listen when I was 20 I took the
time 30:35 my dick was always on [ __ ]
blast double blast even after you come
you know your [ __ ] dick thighs for a
little walk I would come and be right
back that's when I just get that first
horse out of there once I get that first
shot out of there it's all over for that
[ __ ] I'm coming like a salve it's not
anymore I'm a seven year old man I'm not
dick like that that's why the church is
talking to you about blue Chu you're
like what the [ __ ] you talking about
Joey I'm talking about blue chew its a
chewable dick bill which means it works
fast blue Chu has the same fda-approved
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
this ain't no [ __ ] package that you
get the [ __ ] liquor store blue chew
it prescribed online by a licensed
decision and you don't have to go to the
[ __ ] doctors office and wait on line
with another [ __ ] idiot with masks on
this is done right from this rightful
you [ __ ] office there right from the
house and it ships right to your door to
their discreet package it's not gonna
have like a dick on the envelope so the
mailman knows you got [ __ ] dead dicks
nothing like that it ships right through
the door
nobody knows nothing and says blue shoe
[ __ ] [ __ ] ships direct they're cheaper
than the [ __ ] pharmacy and best of
all there's no awkwardness but joy
what's so good about a chewable dick
bill you know what's so good about it
you could take it any time just like
that boom any time day and night even in
a full stomach and since they're
chewable they work up to twice as fast
as a [ __ ] pill turn your [ __ ]
little dead dick come a [ __ ] disgust
into a hot rod of [ __ ] debt you gotta
treat a puss it is the [ __ ]
Indianapolis 500 now that's it they no
[ __ ] around
not heavy and even if you still got good
dick why not [ __ ] add extra [ __ ]
incentive
go to blue chu dot-com right now get
your first shipment for free when you
press inc old church you understand I'm
trying to say to you free what do you
got the [ __ ] free and this is all
prescribed by a physician it's done in
[ __ ] two minutes two [ __ ] minutes
you answer a couple question the guy
pops up tell him and he [ __ ] sends it
to you that's how fast this is you don't
need to leave your [ __ ] house ok so
right now go to blue to DOM and get your
first shipment free and pressing code
Church just pay the final hours for
shipping all right
again that's blue like the color of her
beautiful blue eyes and it's Chu like
when you chew a bubble gum you chew calm
okay
slash Church pressing cold church and
that's it all right I want to thank blue
chew calm and I want to thank CBD
line.com and I want to thank the [ __ ]
deli Oh uncle paulie's in Beverly Hills
and downtown hopefully they're fine and
save them I love you [ __ ] I
don't want to take any more your time on
the up I guess you want to listen to so
far we're on for the 11th to the 13th in
Irvine don't nobody embraer Brea and
improv and Brea the 11th to the 13th
that's the word on the street I don't
know nothing the schedule still has me
on for this Friday and Saturday ain't
nobody gonna sit in the [ __ ] room
this Friday and Saturday and watch
comedy [ __ ] savages out there you
might get looted yourself so I love you
guys with all my heart stay safe stay
black stay strong get it together don't
let nobody [ __ ] with you and that's it I
see you [ __ ] bright and early
Monday morning tip-top Magoo I'll be
sending you a [ __ ] video out this
Friday so keep the eyes open for it just
to check up on you [ __ ] cuz I
love you right kick this [ __ ] melee
[Music]